en este vídeo hablaremos de los
diferentes tipos de discontinuidades que
probablemente ya han visto en álgebra o
en pre cálculo así que vamos a
relacionar esta noción tanto a límites
bilaterales como unilaterales pero
primero veamos un repaso de la
clasificación de discontinuidades del
lado izquierdo podemos ver que esta
curva se parece a la función de la equis
cuadrada hasta que llegamos a x igual a
3 porque en lugar de 3 al cuadrado en
este punto tenemos un agujero y en lugar
de que la función en 3 sea 3 al cuadrado
está definida como 4 continúa como ye
igual a x cuadrada y a esto se le conoce
como discontinuidad evitable
discontinuidad
evitable y se llama así por razones
obvias la función es discontinua en este
punto y podemos imaginar que se define o
mejor dicho se redefine la función y en
este punto vuelve a hacer continua la
discontinuidad es eliminada pero como se
relaciona esto con nuestra definición de
continuidad
bueno recordemos la definición de
continuidad se dice que f es continua si
y sólo si o mejor dicho f es continua en
x igual a c si y sólo si el límite de fx
cuando x se aproxima a c es igual al
valor actual de la función cuando x es
igual a sí entonces por qué fallo aquí
bueno el límite por ambos lados existe
porque si decimos por ejemplo que en
este caso c es igual a 3 el límite
cuando x se aproxima a 3 de fx bueno si
revisamos esto gráficamente sabemos que
esta es la
la equis cuadrada excepto en esta
discontinuidad esto es igual a 9 pero el
problema es que en la forma en la que
está representada esta gráfica esto no
es lo mismo que el valor de la función
porque efe de 3 es decir la forma en la
que esta gráfica da esta función efe de
3 es igual a 4 así que esta es una
situación en la que existe un límite por
ambos lados pero no es igual al valor de
esa función y tal vez se encuentren con
otro tipo de circunstancias en donde la
función aquí todavía no esté definida
aquí no lo está entonces puede que
existe el límite pero la función todavía
no está definida aquí aunque de
cualquier manera no se cumple este
criterio para la continuidad entonces
esta es la discontinuidad evitable
porque existe una discontinuidad con
respecto a la definición del límite de
continuidad y ahora veamos el segundo
ejemplo si analizamos nuestra idea
y va de continuidad de esta gráfica y
tratamos de trazar la podemos ver que
cuando llegamos a x2 tenemos que separar
el lápiz del papel para seguir trazando
así que esa es una forma de saber que es
discontinua como sucede aquí si trazamos
esta función tenemos que separar el
lápiz porque no podemos pasar por este
punto tenemos que brincar hasta acá y
continuar así que como en los dos casos
tenemos que separar el lápiz del papel
esto también es discontinuo pero este
tipo de discontinuidad en el que hay un
brinco de un punto a otro se conoce como
una discontinuidad de salto
discontinuidad de salto
cómo se relaciona esto con los límites
bueno aquí sí existen los límites
derecho e izquierdo pero no son iguales
así que no tenemos un límite por ambos
lados porque por ejemplo para este caso
en particular todos los valores de x
arriba de i incluyendo x igual a todos
aquí tenemos la gráfica de jay x al
cuadrado y después para valores de x
mayores a todos tenemos la gráfica de la
raíz cuadrada de x entonces en esta
situación si tomamos el límite de fx
cuando x se aproxima a 2 desde la
izquierda esto es igual a 4 nos
acercamos a este valor y de hecho este
es el valor de la función pero si
sacamos el límite de fx cuando x se
aproxima a 2 desde la derecha esto a que
será igual bueno al acercarnos desde la
derecha como aquí tenemos la raíz
cuadrada de x nos acercamos a la raíz
cuadrada de 2 pero
no podríamos saber que este es un dos
simplemente observando este punto lo
supimos porque conocemos la función de
esta parte de la gráfica así que está
claro aún visualmente que nos acercamos
a dos valores distintos cuando nos
aproximamos desde la izquierda y cuando
nos aproximamos desde la derecha
entonces aun cuando existen los límites
son y laterales no se aproximan a lo
mismo no existe el límite por ambos
lados y si no existe el límite bilateral
el límite no puede ser igual al valor de
la función incluso cuando la función es
definida por eso es que la
discontinuidad de salto falla en esta
prueba ahora observen que todo esto es
intuitivo aquí vemos que hay un salto
tenemos que separar el lápiz de la
gráfica para continuar porque esto no
está conectado ok y finalmente aquí
podemos ver que bueno
al estudiar pre cálculo a esto se le
conoce como discontinuidad asintótica
discontinuidad asintótica e
intuitivamente nos damos cuenta de que
aquí tenemos una asín tota
tenemos una asín tota vertical en x
igualados y si trazamos sobre la gráfica
desde la izquierda continuaremos y
continuaremos para siempre porque es
infinita y conforme nos aproximamos a x
igual a 2 desde la derecha nuevamente
nos damos cuenta de que esto continúa
así infinitamente sería imposible trazar
toda la función en una vida pero esto
nos ayuda a entender que no hay forma de
que pasemos de aquí a acá sin levantar
nuestro lápiz del papel y bueno si
queremos relacionar esto con la noción
de los límites tanto el límite del lado
izquierdo como el del derecho son
infinitos así que oficialmente no existe
y si no existen no podemos establecer
estas condiciones entonces podemos decir
que el límite de fx cuando x se aproxima
a 2
del lado izquierdo de x podemos ver que
continúa infinitamente en dirección
negativa así que muchas veces pueden
encontrarse algo como esto menos
infinito pero lo más adecuado es
simplemente decir que es notable e
igualmente si pensamos en el límite de
fx cuando x se aproxima a 2 desde la
derecha ahora continúa hacia más
infinito así que esto también es notable
y por esa razón es que este límite no
existe no cumple con estas condiciones
por lo que será discontinuo entonces
esta es una discontinuidad evitable esta
es una discontinuidad de salto porque
tenemos que saltar de un punto a otro y
finalmente tenemos estas assynt o estás
verticales así que esta es una
discontinuidad asintótica